[Music]
to be a good team you need talent and
leadership here is dupreeh gets himself
too
yes he can but to be a great team you
need a heart i i rather want people to
see astralis instead of me and for
astralis that was dupree i put myself in
situations where i couldn't fail he gets
the opening pickers
ready on the lower ramp looking for his
turn
couldn't get even more this is brilliant
dupree wasn't the flashiest player to
don the red and black but he humanized
what many saw as an inhumanly skilled
roster this is the most insane thing
i've ever tried in my entire life we
just keep believing and we just showed
that we're the best team in the world
and of course he was always an integral
part of what many still consider the
greatest lineup in cs go history dupree
is keys instrumental to astralis
victories dupree to play a bag it's also
flashed off eagle works though limited
vision limited weapons doesn't even
matter dude
oh the fourth as well how sick is this
round for him and he's looking for the
eighth the first case the golden era
astralis may be no more but dupree's
story didn't end with that team duprey's
recovered and he's got three he's even
dinked up the fourth as well and he'll
get it he'll confirm and now he might
just get all five one player left and
duprey's got it
peter hartmann
peter dupree rasmussen will always be
remembered as part of the astralis that
won four cs go majors more than any
other team in the game's history to date
on astralis dupree set the standard for
entry fraggers everywhere and this is
where zipfix has to be perfect it's
device out behind the boxes dubri he's
down below he gets all three bombs
dropped that could be the round in
itself 58 seconds and all they have to
do is protect the bomb not to mention a
flank glaives on the scene flaming at
long no chance dude what around four
kills
and he showed the world that not even
the deadliest cs go pro is above
cracking a joke every now and then as i
said it seemed impossible after that one
because it played so well
a device it sounds like there's a party
going on who's whooping in the
background
but before all of that duprey was a
competitive kid growing up in denmark
who spent every waking moment getting
better at counter-strike dabbling in
both 1.6 and source the earliest
[Music]
we had the juice club that usually
allowed you to play 30 minutes a day but
you had to sign up and you had to sign
yourself on the list and that was the
only place we could play because back
then it wasn't that common to have
computers at home so we really wanted to
play there so we sat there and waited at
that list for like an hour before you
could actually sign on just to play 30
minutes i didn't go home and we did like
like every single day for the next for
the past year or something so yeah that
was probably the memory i remember the
most because that was where i started
feeling that i was actually really good
at chemistry in 2010 when the future
superstar was just 17 his dad a man
duprey had looked up to from a young age
was diagnosed with an aggressive form of
chest cancer michael rasmussen made it
through eventually but the ordeal left
dupree and the rest of his family shaken
at the time young dupree would hide away
in his room and play counter-strike as a
way to cope that was where i could laugh
with people is where people didn't know
about all the [ __ ] happening in my life
after graduating high school dupree
doubled down on his dream of becoming a
professional cs player and cs go seemed
like the way forward eventually dupri's
prowess landed him on his very first pro
team the copenhagen wolves and he was
off to a good start right away three on
two with apex and kenny s i've hardly
got anything between them here is
dupreeh gets himself too
yes he can final round but where's the
bomb ring around the roses here does he
have enough time yes he does he's gonna
have time for defuse what a round what a
finish coming out from this first half
the walls were also where dupree first
got to play with two of his eventual
astralis teammates device and zipics the
three stuck together for the next five
years as they cycled through orgs and
their other teammates came and went
dupree found himself moving from
copenhagen wolves to uber geeks to team
dignitas to team solomid and he fragged
out on every one of those teams that's
dupreeh down to 38
but they are going to get control of
this a site team dignitas they've got
the smokes down to cut cloud9 off and in
fact they're going for huge plays two
three
going towards that b bombsite once again
you would expect them to be doing
something pretty fast here with the
smoke grenades perhaps in that shot
three takes down zendo fantastic use of
the new hitboxes there and sprays
through the wall japanese on fire gonna
be taking down sever so well he cannot
be stopped crims goes down it's a 2v2
but then nade comes out from pronax it's
device gordy gone through 231 veto he
gets one he gets a second we're going to
overtime ladies and gents tsm
what a way to pull this one back from
the brink but the next change on the
horizon was bigger than duprey could
have ever imagined
nowadays the name australis conjures up
the image of a specific lineup device
dupree zipix glaive and magisk headed up
by their coach sonic but that wasn't
always the case at its inception in 2015
the roster not only looked different
they also performed way differently than
the astralis we all know and love in
fact choking when it mattered most was
so commonplace it became known as the
astralis curse they're one round they're
not on the knife's edge now and astralis
they do not fare well in this sort of
situation they've been known to crumble
in the past the bomb is being planted
way out in the open and chris is already
waiting on catwalk he actually misses
the shot so dupreeh getting a second
chance at it going to be charging on in
he goes down and mousesports are going
to be in the semi-finals 16-12 over
astralis on dust2 i want to talk to
both of you specifically about the curse
of australia i've interviewed kerrigan
as well and asked them specifically
about it they hate talking about it
they're calling it choking right but it
just keeps happening right it's always
at the semi-finals it's got to be this
mental block but it's so weird because
even it's not it's not even like
apparent to themselves you know
literally after that game ended dupreeh
poked his head in the green room and
went
like they're completely aware of what's
going on but they're not aware maybe
necessarily of why it's happening it
wasn't until glaive entered the picture
as the team's new igl the thing started
looking up for astralis hello i am
glaive i am the newest addition to the
astonish team
yeah i am the in-game leader and
there's not much more to say about that
i always wanted to play with such
amazing talents i think they are all
really good people they have so much
firepower and i want to see how far i
can take it with them a decision was
made to let kirby do the entry fragging
while dupreeh transformed into the role
of a lurker a complete opposite of what
he was used to doing but duprey had no
problem with taking one for the team if
it meant bringing astralis closer to
their ultimate goal so allah and nico
gonna go straight in with glaive to
watch them off dupree to play at bags
could swing back in that direction
because he air isn't going to be
pressure but he doesn't know that it's
also flashed off eagle works though
limited vision limited weapons doesn't
even matter dude
oh the fourth as well how sick is this
round for him and he's looking for the
eighth the first case
from any one of the strollers in this
tournament and now they're getting
pumped
this is not just a game for me this is
this is my kind of my life in some way
like it's a big part of my life and
achieving winning a major is something
that only a
small percentage of this year's school
players achieve since there's also
people that's won in multiple times
so yeah
this this is the dream and if we manage
that dream then yeah the switch combined
with the other changes implemented by
the org including the addition of an
on-staff sports psychologist finally did
the trick not going to be successful
this time maybe it's going to be pasha
put into play walking in looking for the
kill on offer but he misses us by a
little bit of help he goes down pascha
that was the big opportunity now it's
all on the other clutch he gets the head
shot on one goes for a second but dupri
gonna be there triple kill left on six
health in this one it's pretty much a
hard eco from astralis and a huge clutch
coming through for debris at the end
making all the difference here in this
second half
petal
he turns around for it realizing neo
walks in and he gets the shot on cypnex
that leaves dupree one versus two
he has to clutch this australis mentally
they need us to get back into the game
he sees the gun barrel headshot on one
now comes pasha next in line dupreeh
going forward doing the damage and he
gets it one versus two we've said it so
many times in the past the man on your
screen there dupree is key he's
instrumental to astralis victories now
it's a two on three astralis i don't
know how they've got into this situation
but they actually have the man lead
there is key airs they're walking out
into the open one after another vertice
pro
what is this the first half was vertice
pros the second half has been all about
astralis
this is incredible are we going to see
it are straw is going to break the curse
are they going to win their first major
the first time they're in the finals he
goes down with the max 70 can't make it
happen finally pascha coming in with a
refract but he's down the bomb has been
picked up by dupreeh they get the spray
neal takes one and how's it there and
astralis they win the first major
championship
16-14 against vertical
unbelievable
here they are ladies and gentlemen your
major champions astralis
[Applause]
this is the most insane thing i've ever
tried in my entire life like it goes out
to all three maps so we have our backs
against the wall and we just keep
believing and we just show that we're
the best in the world
following their e-league triumph the
team wasn't doing so hot device took a
medical leave leaving dupreeh to
temporarily pick up the orb in his
absence and once again dupree stepped up
in a big way this time i don't think
it's gonna work out
getting the kill on taco but they just
have to play this one safe three of us
is one he's gonna go and isolate a
player who almost gets that
just play it cool now
surely he's used up all of his good
fortune in that previous round 45
seconds left in this one on three he's
got to hope for a mistake
and he's found coldzera
still alive
fur and bolts trying to get together
this bomb is gonna get planted as they
rotate into position but somehow dupreeh
has another chance
there should be absolutely no way in any
universe that this can work out one
versus four awp they knew where he was
the bomb is down and now they're going
to try and double push him they don't
have a kid currently picked up that's a
big problem he gets another kill taken
down
again and again and again decree
winning it for australia
history in the making ladies and
gentlemen
but the biggest shock of that period was
the sudden departure of kierby astralis
youngest member who decided to test his
fortunes elsewhere and signed with north
kirby's spot had to be filled and
quickly astralis ended up picking magisk
as kierby's replacement a move that
solidified the superstar roster that
would go on to smash every cs go record
and expectation as for dupreeh after
jumping from one position to the next
for the last couple of years he was now
able to go back to his preferred role on
the server entry fragging not that it
mattered really dupreeh had proven that
he was a true chameleon who could be
whatever his team needed him to be and
be no worse off for it now how does he
get back into this one they have a
molotov as well grenade gonna land on
him spray right through taking down
glaive i'll show you ray not bad at all
and now gonna follow up he has no smoke
this is incredibly tricky and he's gonna
tap the bomb just holding it down all of
waiting on the other side one more
second and gabriel's gonna get the shot
and he should have the time as well for
the defuse a one-on-two early on to get
astralis on the board that is just very
difficult to do very defensive you can
see one player towards library that's
dupreeh
is it enough as it will be an a-side
finish santaros doesn't seem to think so
but the flashback is perfect and two
three five three he certainly can bomb
down and he brings the round right back
in their favor what a fantastic play
vince the three of mine just got up here
on top of the heart damage done early on
tonight he doesn't get by outside debris
you just can't get past him a legion
with the reply does fine matches but
dupreeh he just keeps on shutting them
down time and time again it's twist
1v3 not meant to be
challenging
that's where the vice will be
challenging as well he gets the opening
pickers in enough to do three ready on
the lower ramp looking for his turn he
can't go couldn't get even more this is
brilliant shadow through the smoke shows
but now zipping knows they're gonna be
on the corner trying to spray the boxes
that gives himself off with the off
dupree couldn't find the second chance
he will on the third as he gets taco
rotating around that brings device into
it and astralis goes six five
it looks like it's a done deal nitro has
not turned up in this final map and
astralis are so close to this point one
kill is gonna secure it and that's it
the grand slam instead itself probably
season 8 as well
matthew can you believe it the first map
it looked like they were out of it they
weren't turning up their key players
weren't there but they adapted
back-to-back ecs back-to-back pro league
martial
season seven
chicago
and now for the first time ever at home
season eight i've scored into the
champions of esl pro league and for the
first time in history the best of all
time until grand slam it destroys
astralis won tournament after tournament
a second major the intel grand slam and
countless others i think one of the
things that defines him stylistically is
his ability to be a jack-of-all-trades
there is just like almost no position
role
anything that's that dupree cannot do
at a tier one level in in counter-strike
he's sort of this glue
or a patch that you can just like slap
on whatever you need right like you need
this guy here he's got it you need this
guy running this gun here he's got it he
can do this to take over the second or
he's got it like he can just do anything
but amidst all the triumphs there was
some sadness as well the team's rigorous
schedule kept dupreeh away from home and
his ailing father for long periods of
time the katowice 2019 manger was coming
up if they could clinch the victory
there astralis would become one of the
most decorated cs go teams to ever exist
but tragically just a few days before
the event dupree revealed the
devastating news that his father had
finally lost his long battle with cancer
while missing out on the major would
have obviously been understandable
duprey instead chose to battle through
his grief and with the support of his
teammates helped australis to make
history this is unexplored no one's done
what they have intel extreme
masters the grand slam last year
back-to-back majors
it's surely 2019 can't possibly be as
good as 2018 but there's no signs of
them slowing down not for dupree either
he'll get two
and walk in the smoke glaive he'll only
punish one but it's just ariel will find
and it's done
they had one goal that's it that's all
they wanted back-to-back and they've
done it now
and the last to join the circle is to
free
how much he had to give to be here how
much he had to give up
the loss of his father
no doubt he'll be smiling down on him
now because he has broken all the
records along with his team
i came into this tournament with my
father uh yeah he passed away just
before i got here and his last wish was
that i
i went here and so i really want to
dedicate this this win to my father
mate come on
in the wake of his personal tragedy
dupree still use
as an escape the one stable thing he
could focus on even when the ground
slipped from beneath his feet the rest
of astralis rallied around him and
driven by the strength of their common
goal to be the absolute best team in the
world the danes went on to win their
fourth major cementing themselves as the
colossi of csgo like this is just
dominance on a level that sometimes it's
hard to to quantify understand it
doesn't resonate with you because you
know what it's so easy to dismiss it as
boring as easy and i understand you know
a close game is exciting and i unders
i'm completely with you there but the
fact of the matter is is that this game
has been around has had professional
players for so damn long and there is a
gap like this
it's possible that astralis would have
just kept on dominating the game for
years to come the results after the
berlin win certainly made it look that
way but in a crazy twist of fate due to
the global pandemic all esports were
forced online and for the first time in
years astralis showed signs of weakness
a bit of a chance for device maybe could
have seen someone chris will shut down
another one and this is just i mean like
every one of these last rounds it's a
complete spiral for astralis regardless
of the fact that you know they haven't
played in such a long period of time
that's still the number one team in the
world from your perspective what you saw
what went wrong
oh there was a lot of things that went
wrong uh the communication was off and
and we got off to a good start on those
two but then they um they
catch back and and won some rounds and
then it was suddenly even then we
started to miscommunicate people are not
communicating enough
as the year rolled on both zipx and
glaive took a hiatus from playing and
temporary stand-ins came one after the
other two pretty unimpressive results
nip have got the a bomb site and
astralis with this double long hole they
do have players looking back but it's
dawned on them too late and now they
have to communicate to the guys down on
b all right so yeah they they do
actually have a and as they try and
rotate off yuki just
what they knew they were in this fight i
don't understand what that's such a
blunder from astralis they run in with
knives out and they lose players on the
rotate into warsay this surely can't be
how it all falls apart they know they're
in a rough spot they know they're in a
rough state right now they don't have
the player's desire to be on the lineup
they had to go out and get snappy he
wasn't even the first choice nothing bad
against snobby i think he's been doing
as good as he could in this lineup you
know under these circumstances but a
fact of the matter is that right now a
team that is supposed to be the best in
the world is performing not even as a
top 10 team both zip and glaive
eventually returned to the team but the
superstar squad just couldn't recapture
their vibe again i imagine it's probably
pretty hard to win three majors in a row
never mind the one they won in 2017 and
you know to kind of be hit really hard
by this sort of online weird limbo that
counter-strike was thrust into but i
also imagine that one of the reasons
it's so hard to recover is because like
honestly
what else is there left to achieve
and the true final death blow to
astralis was the unexpected departure of
device who chose to continue his pro
career elsewhere duprey who was device's
teammate over the span of several years
and orgs was understandably crushed well
obviously nikolai i know that you have
you have made up your decision and
i respect you fully and i'm i'm gonna
start crying now because it's actually
quite emotional
hey peter
appreciate the kind words i will always
love you you are like a brother to me
and the team's results reflected this
profound loss better than anything else
could have like to pre-set it a couple
of days ago astralis is at an all-time
low and i was not too sure whether or
not i believe that after watching this
game yes astralis is nearing an all-time
low the old astralis was now undeniably
dead and gone and duprey had a difficult
choice ahead of him
in december 2021 astralis announced the
departure of not one but three of its
long-time members duprey magisk and
sonic were all moving to vitality
first word to express
the first ratio of the team
i'm actually going to say perfection
and i know that's a really big word but
we had a really good time and i don't
think we could have like had a better
start
of course it's hard to say what dupri's
future on this new team will look like
but if his time on astralis is any
indication dupree can adapt to and
thrive in any situation and vitality is
no different that is a crazy move again
from rain is it enough to secure the map
here kerrigan with a headshot and down
in the pit alone fighting is the free
incredible transfer and he's going to
keep going inline up it's a quad at the
end shutting down the offense it's going
to be all out middle no one coming
boiler all the pressure is going to be
in the pre but he's handling it
incredibly well he's not a one-trick
pony he's not a a luxury player if you
will right like you can always no matter
kind of age or composition or anything
like you you can kind of always find a
place on a roster like that right he's
the guy who's willing to be the selfless
sacrificial team player dupree already
made history by becoming one of the
first players to win four cs go majors
three of them back to back and he did it
all on astralis a team whose success he
always valued above individual
recognition this game is so much more
about
team play than any other game and
obviously
you combine it with being good
individually but i think our team play
is very unique in so many ways so i i
rather want people to see astralis
instead of me
now dupreeh has a chance to start over
to build a legacy outside of playing
second fiddle to one of the world's best
orcas to prove to everyone that he is
capable of shining on his own and to
finally be celebrated as the undeniable
one in a million talent he's always been
dupreeh this is so fast he's not ready
for this oh he's looking back and he's
got one in a second
dupree's recovered and he's got three
he's even tinked up the fourth as well
and he'll get it he'll confirm and now
he might just get all five one player
left and three's got it
[Music]
you